I was looking at just War index or
people trying to measure
trying to put a number and what wars are
seen as just and not oh really I've
never seen that it's there there's
numbers behind it it's it's great so
it's great because again as you do an
extensive
quantification of Justice you start to
think what actually contributes to our
thought that for example World War II is
a just war and other Wars are not
a lot of it is about intent and some of
the other factors like that you look at
which is prolonged the degree of
violence that is necessary versus not
necessary given the greater good some
measure of the greater good of people
all those kinds of things the then
there's reasons for war you know looking
to free people or to stop a genocide
versus uh conquering land all those
kinds of things and people try to put a
number behind it and a lot based on I
mean what I'm trying to imagine is I
mean suppose I wake up and or that is
whatever my I suppose I think my God
tells me to do something
or or my my God thinks that uh or my
moral sense thinks that something that
another group is doing is repugnant
I'm curious like are they evaluating
like the validity that claimer just the
idea that like well you said it was
repugnant you deeply believe that
therefore it's just I think uh now could
be corrected on a lot of this but I
think this is always looking at Wars
after they happened
so it's and trying to take a Global
Perspective from all sort of a General
survey of how people perceive so you're
not weighing disproportionately the
opinions of the people who waged the war
yeah I mean I I kind of ended up dodging
that because
I mean one is to just point out that
Wars
actually most words aren't necessary and
so in the sense that there's there's
another way to get what you wanted
um and so on on one level there's no
just War now that that's not true
because take an example like the U.S
invasion of Afghanistan the United
States has been attacked
uh there's a culpable agent reliable
evidence that this is Al-Qaeda they're
being sheltered by in Afghanistan by the
Taliban and then the Taliban this is
this is a bit murky it seems that there
was an attempt to
say hand him over or else and and they
said no way now you can make an argument
that
invading and attacking us strategically
the right thing to do in terms of
sending signals to your future enemies
or you just if you think it's important
to bring someone to Justice in this case
Al Qaeda then then you maybe that's just
war or that's a just Invasion but it
hinges on the fact that
the other side just didn't do the
seemingly sensible thing which is a
okay we'll give them up and uh and so so
it was completely avoidable
in one sense but if you believe and I
think it's probably true if you believe
that for their own ideological and other
reasons
um AR particular in Taliban in general
decided we're not going to do this
uh then then now you you're not left
with very many good choices
uh and now I you know I didn't want to
talk about is that a just war is that
what's Justice or not I just wanted to
point out that like it
one side's intransigence if that's
indeed what happened one side's
intransigent sort of maybe compels you
to basically eliminates all of the
reasonable Bargains that you could be
satisfied with and now you're left with
really no other strategic option but to
invade I think that's a slight
oversimplification but I think that
that's like a that's like one way to
describe what happened